Norton and Friends wonderboy Thompson
tyron woodley
and Frankie Edgar what's going on guys
how's it going man it's good to see you
how are you doing great how's it going
man
welcome boys oh yeah if you want yeah if
you want so you can hear yourselves oh
yeah welcome to the show guys thank you
you're up early to to promote the same
um promo all day pretty much all day I
think we get done it like nude oh yeah
yeah then we have press conference
earlier today but yeah I got in late
last night
you know tour in the city and doing
little promo videos last night when you
get in till probably 1 o'clock I just
get up early this morning how big is it
I guess for all of you that you get to
be on the New York card is that that in
your mind or for you guys is it just a
fight as a fight as a fight yeah it's
big for me I'm a Jersey guy you know I
was one of the first people helping
lobbying up in Albany with UFC trying to
get sanctions so yeah I'm excited to be
you know on the first card here in New
York yeah I'm doing good I'm good it's
Madison Square Garden how do you not get
excited for it yes well the top
performers want to perform at and first
UFC fight ever in New York Madison
Square Garden so has dope to be on the
card sure your mic just went out Jim
yeah yeah just pop in a minute ago you
news mine to fidget with the wires
I heard the wires popping so maybe
there's Mars kind of wandering around in
the hallway yeah so um I I was saying
before you guys got in here
that to me it's odd the two people that
would fight each other would be able to
kind of be in the same room at the same
time not that you guys are gonna not be
able to maintain yourselves but the fact
that there's not there's not an
overwhelming hatred you know to start
this thing it's like a month out that's
why yeah yeah it's a professional sport
you got to be professional and tender
today we're gonna fight so nothing you
kind of do right now and dictate the
outcome of the fight but you ever said
the you Tyron don't respect
even as a man right because I felt like
we knew we were fighting longer than
when I said something on Fox yeah and if
you know I'm fighting you and then from
that point you almost act as if I'm not
fighting you know stratified you right
like my resume speaks for itself I don't
think I've been scared to fight any guy
mm-hmm yeah I didn't respect that and we
didn't to be honest I we didn't actually
know until he actually announced it on
Fox I knew there were some things going
back and forth but nothing was happening
that I knew until the day he announced
it so did you think he was afraid to
fight you know I mean everybody was like
you know is he afraid to fight I was
like I don't I don't think he's afraid
to fight me I mean if he is he's you
know he he hasn't ever show that he was
he's never been afraid of a fighter and
it was not afraid of me you know I got
into it with him on Twitter that was
interesting to say yeah you know a
little fireworks there I'm not going
back wait is my dad seriously going back
and forth right now have any like fight
training at all or is he just somebody
who defends you no man he's actually
fought back in the 70s and 80s only 61
now you know he just trains fighters
right now and yeah man I guess you know
I'm his son and you know how I got but
do you not like your dad antagonizing
guy that you have to fight like that
help promote the fight a little bit too
you know I mean I think everything uh
promoter fight people like don't realize
what it means to submit a legacy when I
think about my career and the guys I
fought and I think about the guys that
are out there you know I mentioned
fighting my George st. Pierre some of
these other guys and everyone made it
seem as if hey I was passing over Wonder
Boy that's not what's happening you know
Frankie will tell you that if you get
opportunity to fight against legendary
guys like that that puts that notch on
your belt and take you to the next level
we're both trying to submit ourselves as
legends in this sport and that's why I
said that so when people are all you're
scared it's crazy because the fans don't
understand they don't understand behind
the scenes you understand the financial
side of it and they understand what we
go through as fight or so
I just had to sit back and just do like
this for a while cuz you're looking for
the highest-profile fight not even that
I mean Wonder Boys beaten two top guys
at one former champion one former
contender so it's nothing it's not a
high profile fight but things have a way
of working itself out and as we saw
yesterday you know I'm gonna be in a
position where you know I want to be at
anywhere
did you guys how did you stop like
getting a piece of the gate when did you
find out that Conor and Eddie was the
actual main event when I woke up from my
getting a massage last night now you say
massage in air quotes very different
than when when Jim wakes up with it yeah
it's usually I'm apologizing honey so
very happy
oh yeah I mean I you know it's gonna be
probably the biggest card at UFC history
you know what why would you want to be a
part of that
isn't that crazy to be a part like it
was psychologically what's that like to
because first there was UFC 100 right
and they say this is the biggest card
ever and like UFC 200 they're like okay
now this is the biggest card ever UFC
205 cuz it's in New York now this and
it's such like a young sport that each
one of these things is the biggest card
in history where both of them were Conor
fights to the last one they said was
that's right it was Diaz and then this
one they're saying are the are the two
biggest in history when you have
something like that going it's like the
mentality I have an opportunity here to
be theoretically the if you're still
doing the biggest shows in history
anyone here would have the opportunity
to be the biggest fighter in history
right is that something that you guys
think about or is that I just try to go
out there and perform you know I look at
the legacy endgame I mean legacy is
something you talk about I think when
you're older right me right you got to
think about it I mean I'm definitely
towards the more lit ladder of my career
but I'm not worried about that stuff
told you I'll be 35 next month it's
weird to be that young and look at it's
like it's so that's that's what a fleet
go through the latter part of your
career it's like you're still in your
early eighties yeah I mean you know I'm
not putting a number on anything but you
know I mean Father time doesn't wait for
anybody
well gia and GSP too if you had fought
him he's he has in Fort Worth three
years now or in two years
it's been a while I mean it would
because I think you would he wouldn't do
too well at this point you'd be
surprised man these guys are still
training you know just because you take
time away from the sport he never
retired from the sport and you know I
think he was a few years ahead of the
game anyway
so maybe the game is caught up where to
where to be more competitive at that
time he was dominating Johnny hain just
gave him a run for his money a lot of
people talk Johnny had won that fight so
before they and he was just head and
dominating performance at the dominating
performance do you feel you've been
given the respect you deserve as a
champion um I don't really worry about
that be honest because the time I would
have to take to go out there and try to
make everyone like you and try to make
everyone understand why you're doing I
have a very clear sight on what I want
to do in this sport and you know how I
want to do it and I'm doing that so if
it takes my whole career for people to
give me the respect and that's fine
because I really don't do it for
everyone to like me or not like me to
think think of me as a role model I do
it for my family I do it for the people
that support me those people I want to
prove right instead of taking the
negative energy trying to prove
everybody wrong like I can go to Twitter
and I can like have 300 messages I'm
like go to work sometimes you get it's
hard not to get into it on Twitter once
in a while like some of these people
call me a light tyrant get off that now
like I got two or three people that no
one to get me off so I just well it's
hard not to come back because you used
to you you're not used to somebody
confronting you and backing off it yeah
but you also gotta understand who these
guys are really I mean these guys who
sit at home and watch TV all day long
what it word it you know a lot of you
guys they have no idea what it's like to
actually step out there and actually not
faceless yeah and it's like it's just
it's like the best comeback and then I
just not and sometimes I really free
people out all DM them I'll be like can
I suck your dick
but you uh but it's also like I feel
like you guys probably get it worse than
a lot of people because the people who
would attack anonymously are probably
specifically gonna want to go after guys
who they couldn't you can't do that face
to face with any of you because you're
trained fighters if anybody's not gonna
get it face to face from people like
that it would be you guys because you're
known to rip people's face we also give
them full exposure like no other sport
do you see the athletes just walk
through the MGM Grand or you see them
doing it um
assigning for two hours where fans can
just come up and get as many autographs
or pictures they want we give us we give
our fans that access to us time and time
again and then I think they get used to
it and sometimes they they take it for
granted abuses so they think because
they at the shows they had to pay per
views I mean they bond a pay-per-view
today you know getting these autographs
they feel like now they own a piece of
our company they bought shares into our
company right tell us how to fight who
we should fight what would she do and we
love them and they're extremely
passionate we just got to take it with a
grain of salt and now let it affect you
I was watching one time I was watching
Dana sign and there was a big group of
people and he went over to the stands
and it was just he was actually using
people's cell phones to take the and I'm
like that's why this one of the reasons
the sport is so popular because you guys
are accessible and you need to fan so
well and you know like boxers you can't
get near and they don't give you the
fight you want I've said that a bunch of
times and so with you see you get the
fights that you want to say it's really
it's great yeah when you I guess is for
any guys but like when you see something
like McGregor who is obviously a draw
and you know part of the reason is the
draw is because the way you can talk
right part of this do we can sell fights
does that make you guys think to
yourselves I gotta learn how to do that
too that's becoming part of this game or
do you stick to just being like you know
what let me just stick to what's
happening in the cage I gotta be just
just myself I mean if I've actually
started that now people just be like you
know what Stephen just sit down dude
what are you trying to do so you know
all I can do is really go out there and
just perform the best I can and you know
hopefully that's exciting enough right
and Tywin you said you didn't think that
Stephen was as humble
he comes off you see him cuz you're such
a nice guy you were very genuinely nice
dude and you said you didn't yeah I mean
I just think that you know maybe I was
maybe I was misconstrued that I knew
about this fight if he was asking for
the fight just in the past when I've
asked for a particular fight when a
fighter got anywhere near about except
in the fight especially the way I go
after Joe and those guys they would have
told me that a he's gonna bring some
Simon's fight like this was like when I
say weeks I mean weeks like I was asking
for about agree Mike whereas about
agreement was about agreement was about
agreement and it was maybe math said six
weeks I was way off so it was not six
weeks it was definitely several weeks
before though where I actually said then
I just you know maybe that wasn't the
sequence but I just find a very odd that
the champion says yesterday challenging
any challenge is not know not notified
so you think he might have known I think
he might have known he thinks that's I
don't think that I can break that cuz I
text data and I ask them and at that
point I did me I had set some legal
stuff for my bother gaming Dana never
let us announce to fight without a
bottle gaming have you ever been able to
do that no so I was caught about
agreement yeah so it's not official
until you you sign my bottle green
wasn't even signed yet and he texted me
said go ahead and run me to go ahead and
announce it so in my mind the knowledge
was there so maybe I could be wrong
right but probably you don't think so
though cuz Dana White you want it you
want to get so far Dana White's a smart
businessman sitting between them I got a
table I got enough room to duck under it
is you're dead like a cage dad like does
he sit there and like is he very and
because like my dad listens to like
every radio show I do always calls me
after that's my daughter
he's up there you know if I do a you
know an interview he said which one
isn't man I gotta look it up so you know
we went to school back in Simpsonville
upstate Kearney we're always teaching
classes so I always catch him you know
when he's supposed to be teaching
classes he's in the office looking at
you know listen to my my radio interview
from the next day
so yeah man he tries to listen to every
every one of them
you were Franky you were talking about
being 35 and being on the other side of
it on in terms of age I guess it makes
me think of CM Punk who was 37 when he
just debuted and didn't do so great were
you guys at all surprised like look I'm
a pro wrestling fan
I didn't think CM Punk would win I
thought that he wouldn't bother going
for it if he wasn't gonna be able to do
something and then I mean to my eyes he
didn't do anyone thought I did not know
no he did very very poorly I didn't know
what to expect I mean timer transitive
than any of us I think what uh yeah I
don't know what to expect I seen him
warming up in the back and that's when I
was little like uh you know it looks too
fluid oh really
a little nervous for you know yeah so
you kind of said you're like that's not
that's not at this stage it's not he
trained hard though this is really yeah
yeah seriously but you know I mean
you're ready 37 years old it's just a
touch it's efficient so you're not
getting give him credit for that and you
trained with him tiring yeah that's
right I trained with him a little bit
and the thing about Punk is he trained
so hard it made you want to go like I
went out on my own dime to go and
support him and watch them because
anybody to put that kind of work in the
gym like for two years
Harvard long whatever I don't know if
they signed my year too obviously my
weeks are off you know it been awhile
and he had been doing like three days
boxing privates
you know jiu-jitsu private lessons then
he finally got incorporates at a pro
training and I mean he took his lumps
and he just kept coming back every
single day driving up from Chicago so I
had to support that and and we didn't
expect
Mickey gotta take him down if I was
fighting against CM Punk and I'm like
he's you know older you know and he
hasn't fought before I'm gonna try to
exploit a striking so we can see I was
gonna come out and you know shout out
strike him so we wanted to close the gap
and he's just basically ran into a
takedown and never had a chance to even
show anything he worked on so so the
minute that the minute you Seagal kind
of going for a takedown he's basically
it looked like he was running the ball
and he got tackled right so swinging
that's when I was like
they swung and missed and he just ducked
under me took him down pretty easily
it's kind of hard to combat with a brown
belt yeah I don't think a whole lot of
people understand what kind of pressure
probably heat was going through knowing
that you know everybody's expecting him
to lose he's probably working his butt
off man right to prove them wrong yeah I
got to the point where I was like man I
want he's gotta win I want you to win
you know what I mean yeah to be that
Cinderella story yeah but it's also you
guys have to think it's kind of good for
the sport that he lost so badly right
like is it it lets everybody know that
you can't just jump into this like this
it kind of gives credit to all you guys
that have been doing it your whole lives
you know what I mean that you can't just
jump in halfway through your life train
for a couple years and and do it's not
possible yeah you know I mean NBA player
can't just come over and say hey I want
to fight in UFC I mean right maybe we
could maybe you could maybe have Tom
Cruise verse I think he just had no base
to like you you think about Brock Lesnar
who came over he had a wrestling basis
the National Champion you got guys are
you know Metreon who was an NFL football
player but those guys had wrestling
right you have some form of martial art
in your base to draw from I think you
can learn a little quicker he just did
not have the jujitsu the karate the
Taekwondo the strike in the boxing or
wrestling as a base before pro wrestling
so I think he just kind of had to learn
everything and at that age you know he
is yeah I told my had to pull the
intervention on because he's too many
damn doughnuts enjoying it yeah but I
was one of the fighters root against him
just for that same reason because I see
someone do stand-up comedy like some
actor wants to try being funny who do I
root for him the [ __ ] first it was
like that but as he got closer to time I
was like man this is you can see in his
face like you know that there's a lot
more pressure than what this guy's
actually you know you know showing so I
was like man you know I was like rootin
for this guy respect him for us
seriously yeah it wasn't like he was
just you know trying to be a name to
just jump in a sport he took it
seriously when you hooked up with a good
team he made a good run for it but and
he walked away from a lot of money he
could have made a lot more if you just
stayed in WWE
I'm over the guy that he was just you
know this guy's got your striker and
grappler I'm like man really no pair of
muff so what point like you in this
process for any of you does it get to
the point where you're at like like
battle mode like as you were saying when
you got in here not you general so when
I'm in the gym that's that's when you're
like in the zone mm-hmm you know outside
of that if you live that I guess I don't
know all the time I don't know if that
would be exhausting or it must be
difficult I think about that because
like psychologically like you have to
stay in that mode when you're in the
Octagon is it ever difficult like
because if you slip out of it even for a
second I would imagine like oh no I'm in
trouble like if you're not sitting there
ready to kill right when you're out
there yeah yeah I mean you have to stay
on point especially with with a guy like
this I mean I he's the champion for a
reason so you go out there and it for a
split second you're not you know you
know ready or you know anything could
happen he could sit there and knock you
out as you saw his last fight right you
know you don't know what was going
through all his head at that moment like
it was a shocking I mean it wasn't
shocking that you won but to knock a guy
like that out that quickly because such
a tough dude and to see him beaten so
completely was shocking
by the way that facial expression on
Orton's face just now was the immediate
thought of like what would my face look
like if I was getting knocked out yeah
let me just make this point very quickly
when you see a guy get beaten that a
great champion like that and he's a
tough dude Robbie Lawler and it seemed
get beaten that fast is just it's always
a surprise to see you weren't surprised
though I would I would quote Nate Diaz
quote I was not surprised I thought that
you know I always put myself in a
position where I feel like I can be
successful and
at any point anybody can get knocked out
but I just think that the fans don't
realize how long I've been doing this
how hard I've been training and it
wasn't a night off for Robbie I just was
a better fighter and I think that's what
happened I beat him and it wasn't it
wasn't that I did something special
I saw a punch I took the punch and I
finish it off the job so I wasn't
surprised that one was that surprised
that happen in the first round possibly
I thought he would you know being kind
of looking for me to come out you know
guns blazing but just in general I had
prepared to come out gun blazing for
five rounds so now wasn't surprised
there's just certain things that
happened that as a guy watching a lot of
fight sounds like I was surprised that
Conor beat Nate in a five round decision
I never saw that coming
I never would have taken that bet that
he was gonna win a five round decision
you know there's certain things
happening like wow so you never thought
I was gonna win the fight I know you
were in the fight but I just didn't
think that Robbie would get knocked out
that fast you know because I hope you
know after what he did to uh you know to
Johnny and I just didn't see him getting
knocked out immediately that's what
makes this game so exciting though you
know I mean you really don't know at
this point I mean because the game is
always evolving who's gonna win I mean
who do you pick because you never know I
mean look at who was a Bisbing in Rock
Hill nobody thought that Bisbing would
sit there and knock him out I remember
what around it was in but yeah I mean
you never know but you're now right
you're fighting a guy in a month and a
half who just across the table from you
said he was planning on coming out guns
blazing all five rounds so don't it
didn't matter
like are you sitting there going like oh
it does have the ability to do that I I
don't that happened not at all man I
mean you know in my head every fire that
face I'm thinking it's gonna be the
toughest fight of my life and you know
you've got to be prepared yeah you've
got to be prepared prepared for that are
you sad like are you looking it's kind
of at least psychologically at this
point sizing each other up and like are
you looking in his eyes and vice versa
to see if there's any fear whatsoever no
no I know this guy's not you know have
you ever found I've always been able to
look into guy's eyes and see what type
of fight on my that's for when you're in
the weigh-ins I'm not trying to talk so
if I'm not trying to go on nuts but I
can look at your eyes I can see what
kind of fight I've looked in guy's eyes
on my dis dudes coming to he's going to
war some guys have been indecisive like
nah I'll cross honey he didn't know how
to deal with me I can tell he didn't
have
the Rubik's Cube figured out in some
guys I just felt like you know [ __ ] I
shake he just had this defeated look in
his eye and I knew I was gonna get a
monitor so I'll be I'll be staring in
deep and see and see what kind of fight
on me but it's like I'm down for any
fight to be honest yeah plus I got like
Aldo not look you in the eye though I
notice when he walks out maybe I'm just
seeing it wrong but like he seems to
like kind of look down yeah I think it
wanes we looked at each other but like
the square up in a cage he looks down I
don't like what do you think that's
about cuz I mean he's obviously not
afraid ya know some guys like to act
crazy some guys look down does it affect
you anyway you don't get me do you
Frankie do you do you feel the same way
as Tyron like when you at the weigh-ins
when you look at somebody in the eyes
can you tell a lot about the fighter or
is that not can but sometimes you know
it shows you off you don't know all
right I don't try to figure people out
but because the last thing you want to
do is like see weakness and the guy's
eyes come in overconfident realized oh
no that wasn't weakness yeah yeah do you
have a ritual when you walk into the
cage I'm always amazing guys who walk in
a certain way and then you'll see a guy
like steepen Miocic who just kind of
walks in just cash as well yeah with
nothing and in this I was talking
regular and who's a a so what are you
doing uh I gotta go out there and fight
yeah man
I mean you know before the fight I don't
walk out there any certain way but
before the five man I'm I'm back there
sleeping I sleep right up until you do I
get up I warm up a little bit next thing
you know I'm back there I'm just gonna
set me up for a loop there but I'm I
don't take it so yeah I yeah I was
fifteen this is one way that I cope with
the with everything you know what I mean
just by just sleep are you an easy
sleeper in general like oh my god lay
down this table policy right now and
then nice to have that kind of I'm a
drives me cry
I sleep in a king bed and you're dozing
off in the back in the locker room
before you fight in a title fight you're
they said that we interviewed dr. J one
time and he said that for him it's being
able to sleep anywhere is one of the
greatest advantages because you always
have extra energy over your opponent he
could city could doze off in the car on
a bus anyway I just can't do it
oh man I love my sleep Leslie wake up
you know the cracker noon you know get
ready to go through it through the day I
love muscle you've got to have at least
15 hours what about you Frankie do you
have any rituals before a fight this way
something goes wrong or something
different happens you're not like all on
the same got to tape your hands right
right you just worry about again you're
more of a task at hand guy let me just
make sure I do my job tonight yeah just
show up get the job done and move on
yeah Tyron Jim our guys are my division
I'll bring something different everybody
is a completely different fighter but
everyone does at least one of two things
real dangerous so I might have a
different training partner so I might be
doing something different but I just
want to make sure I'm warm
that I got a good stretch in and as long
as I get that I'm good I got you did you
guys watch the debates last night no I
watched all the filters that they put on
there but you missed the debate that's
not really your isn't that nice when you
could be like what you can excel at this
level of fighting you really are not
responsible for knowing what else is
going on in the world you like as long
as I focus on this is what I have to do
I don't think those who know what's
going on in the world yeah think about
this election I think just both of them
are they rub certain people wrong way
and I was like almost like what are we
gonna do for the next one year either
way either way you know we have for a
surprise yeah yeah what did you do
before you fought when you were younger
what did you do wrestle all you did you
know Russell forever did you always want
to be a fighter before that did you have
something I want to play football to be
honest with my coaches in high school
I was gonna be too small which I end up
not being too small but I was going to
play football but I wrestled as well so
I had a chance to go to college for
wrestling so I said I'm gonna do that
tyranny also a podcast
yeah the morning was show that was that
actually Jessica gave us a stamp of
approval we went to the fans and try to
get try to get two names for the podcast
cuz me and Deena you idiot sometimes so
we decided to become these nuts and
since my name is a Woodley we decide to
go with the morning wood show okay can't
forget it the two of you combined or
Deez Nuts yeah in the morning what
channel with these nuts I figure you get
this no no he got what morning wood was
he just didn't know he didn't
the problem is with Jim he just thought
morning what he didn't realize that was
your name I know you do in Florida no we
actually we do satellite so one time I
was in India Dean was in Korea and the
producer was in their life so technology
is just crazy while you're in India I
was in a movie in India Indian actually
anime movie called so time and the most
popular actor in India I think he's
probably fourth to fifth overall in the
world for as far as much as much money
to make like 50 or 60 million a year
which is nuts so I did that movie and
it's like broke every international
record so is that what you want to get
into acting or is that just a thing you
I do it in between if I just want to
have a chance but I just have seen guys
in the past that focus too much on
entertainment and take away from
fighting so I'll turn I've turned down
four or five projects and you know
people looking names like oh how can you
turn it down and I'm like well that's
almost like you asked me how much money
we make because you don't understand
that fighting you're only gonna make
this type of money you know disappears
in your life and the movies things will
be afterwards is that what you think
happened to ride around see no I just
think she lost I mean that wasn't I
think she lost a fight against a girl
they had a good game plan against her
and that was it mm-hmm I don't think you
know distracted by the Entertainer
world around distracted by owning a gym
you can get distracted by sitting up on
social media all day so distractions can
come however II wonder but I think she
was a high level athlete where she
managed it for so long that I don't
think it was that big of a distraction
you know she was probably better
tolerated
she just got beat mm-hmm and how about
you any act you anything I'm amazed by
how many fighters do do these like
entertaining yeah and I mean I mean if
it comes my way then probably but as of
right now just full-time fighter man I
can't wait to dad threatens to beat up
every bad movie you like we've 47:57 no
as a kickboxer 57 or no as a kickboxer
so was your first professional loss
against Matt Brown yep sure was it was
my second fight in the UFC what was that
like taking it after that many wins oh
my goodness you know it was of course
that you know you felt bad but that was
probably the best fighter I've ever had
as of you know what I mean just just
just with the change after and what I've
learned during that fight that was the
fight I mean it was rough I mean the
whole the whole process you know was I
was new I mean I had my first fight in
2010 and then in 2012 and fighting Matt
Brown so I was like you know I didn't
have the wrestling didn't have the
jujitsu the first day that UFC called I
was about I was gonna turn him down
because I felt I wasn't ready is there a
pressure that leaves like after your
first loss you know I mean that you
don't have to maintain that sort of
undefeated yeah there was a crazy amount
of hype you know me coming into the UFC
if in for a beginner you know fighting
for the UFC at first and just with that
first loss it just kind of all went away
it wasn't as much pressure and now I can
just go out there and fight you know you
always wanted being undefeated was
harder like when Rhonda was I think 10
or 12 or 13 you know whenever I just
keep saying numbers and then she finally
lost it maybe it [ __ ] with her but it
seems like if you get a loss out of the
way it's you don't have to obsess over
you know being undefeated for the rest
of your career but you think you'll
probably win at Madison Square Garden of
course oh good Tara's get what how come
you get into podcasting oh just because
it's our our own filters it's the way we
can communicate and let people know
what's on our mind and
to make it specific for whether it's UFC
or fox or whatever so just we could have
fun we can go over topics politics and
you just our way of kind of expressing
myself Dana doesn't care what you say or
we can't just go out there and go ham on
it but I think in general we we get edgy
sometimes but I don't think we just go
you know in the place where we put our
jobs in jeopardy well the kind of stuff
Dana says too which is great he never
seems to hold back so that's got to be
an advantage of a boss suit and even
works with what I do I'm looking for a
fight so he's one of the guys on that
show with Dana so I think you kind of
know Dana a little bit more and if it's
something that we've I shouldn't say
before anyone do it
have any of you ever gotten scolded by
Dana White because I mean I started
becoming fascinated by it
after Brock Lesnar and his run with UFC
not this last one his run run when he
did is his promo about Bud Light and
everything and then you know half an
hour later was apologizing because
obviously the wrath of Dana had come
down have any of you ever had to I
haven't experienced that yet but I've
heard some stories yeah I mean you know
I heard he's you know he's pretty rough
if you know you're doing something
you're not supposed to be doing but I
haven't haven't felt that wrath yet
he's texted me some stuff he didn't like
I said yeah yeah and I just was talking
[ __ ] about some fights that I didn't get
or some an interview and he said I sound
like a maniac and this and then tells
your problem it was cool you know
yeah did you apologize I just forgot
right lol
[Music]
calling fighters that seems to be like
the guys that do that like Mickey gall
got himself - CM Punk fight yeah calls
out sage Northcutt there's something
about that that you know it seems to it
seems to work it's entertainment man
traction to it you know makes this story
Tyron was unusually silent when he was
talking about getting scolded by Dana
White has he yelled at you or known I
think he's Oded you know anybody who's
asking for certain amount of money or
fights everybody if you know Dana he's
gonna he gets over things really fast
he's not gonna hold a grudge and you
know just in general it's business and I
think he's used to doing
so how do you guys lock out once you
really get into training mode like how
do you lock out the rest of the world
like we were talking about you know not
focusing on the debate or whatever but
I'm assuming once training starts you
really have to not only lock out what
else is going on in the media or
whatever but I mean like everything
right to just to focus in on what's
going on you gotta have a circle that's
what it is you just walk in there
certain things that are important so in
things that are important so you should
reach you so if you have a good filter
in a good circle that make sure that
things that are important to your
training and you know doing well in the
fight that you know and have knowledge
of and things that aren't you don't how
long does it take you to establish that
circle like you know time you so you
have to get a trial in there right
you got to constantly evaluate it
because sometimes you start making it a
jump and some people start jumping out
in the circle right right
is it hard not to feed into the other
stuff I mean for me it's almost
impossible I can't cut we talked about
Tiger Woods a lot and his whole crazy
ritual when he finally got you know when
it all fell apart he stopped playing
golf well I thought part of it was that
was probably part of his ritual part of
the stress relief was doing all this
crazy texting is it hard not to feed
into that outside stuff man for me none
at all I mean I know when you're [ __ ]
when you got a fight that's all you
focus on you know of course you've got
little things little breaks in there
that you do so you're not thinking about
all the time so it's not too crazy but
you know for me it's teaching classes
but yeah man it when it's when it's time
to Train is business you actually like
teaching classes love it love it man I
didn't become the fighter I am you know
if it wasn't for teaching too I started
teaching when I was 15 and I'm in
something about you have to understand
it more when you have to teach it
especially the kids you know what I mean
so it's it's fun man it's fun we party
down is your dad gonna be at the garden
oh yeah he will I'm gonna made what
whose corner just got into have you ever
had your corner was it
Fabricio Werdum he threw a kick yeah and
literally front kick them you know you
never know who's gonna kick cuz you got
a big country kick in the
yeah yeah so that's yeah last weekend
yeah yeah that was I was I that's one
thing I've never seen before as a ref
getting kicked in the ass I got a new I
think he was oh well the the fight
happens November 5th at Madison Square
Garden there's going to be a press
conference tonight what Sam sorry does
they try to sabotage your city no wow
November 12th at Madison Square Garden
there's a press conference tonight at 6
p.m. at the theater at Madison Square
Garden there's free tickets available to
fans at the Madison Square Garden box
office for the press conference
tickets to UFC 205 are gonna go on sale
on Friday but I mean to say this will
sell out quick would be the
understatement of the century
this card is is amazing we talked to Dan
yesterday for an hour and of course he
didn't tell us that he actually had
Connor and Eddie as the main event are
you guys the coming I think so yeah it's
the welterweight championship I mean
tyron woodley against Stephen Tom yeah
and in Jade chick against a co-worker I
can never say Carolina's last name so
just say Joanna's fighting it's gonna be
good well thank you guys yeah Jimmy good
man it's gonna be a good night yes thank
you guys
we're gonna take a break we'll be right
back